Tengo una gran noticia que darte, amigo que has pulsado en este vídeo, que le has dado a clic y has dicho a ver que me cuenta esta gente.
Te voy a dar motivos por los que los recién ascendidos de la Premier League se van a salvar. ¡Vamos!
¡A primera hoy! ¡A primera hoy!
Eh, ya. Calma. Porque todavía había que haber mucha temporada.
Pero amigos, es el resumen del vídeo. A primera porque se van a mantener en primera.
¡A primera es cuando asciendes! Claro, claro, claro. En este caso es a primera que se quedan en primera.
En primera, ¿no? Tendría que ser. Habría que repetirlo.
¡A primera! ¡A primera! Pero qué bajón de cántico, ¿no?
¡A primera! ¡Celebrad donde ya estás! Es el cántico más mediocre de la historia.
Amigos, tenemos algo bueno que deciros.
Hemos montado un vídeo en el que hemos encontrado razones para pensar que los tres recién ascendidos, después de muchos años haciendo el ridículo, se van a mantener en la primera division.
¡Otro aplauso! ¡Otro aplauso! ¡Otro aplauso!
¡Aviso! Hemos encontrado razones. Ya con eso...
Hay razones soportadas por los hechos. Hay otras que tienen que ver con la fe.
Así que aquí hay ciencia y también hay religión. Está todo en este vídeo.
Todo cubierto. Pero chozas, tengo que decirte que tras siete jornadas, la temporada pasada, los recién ascendidos sumaban la friolera de once puntos.
Increíble. Bien, pues entre todos, esta temporada, tras los mismos partidos y con esos músculos que Dios le ha dado a Dan Ballard, suman veintitrés puntazos.
¡Vaya voz! Dime que no es para creer.
De hecho, once tiene solo el Sunderland.
¡Qué bonito! Once el Sunderland, ocho el Leeds y cuatro el Berlín.
Bueno, pero también te digo una cosa. Es el único de los tres que está en descenso y a un punto de la salvación.
Así que he decidido ponerme absolutamente optimista.
Quien venga en este vídeo a darme razones por las que no van a bajar, yo sé.
Ahora la gente me va a venir.
¿Y es que en tus predicciones pusiste a los tres y tal?
Que se muera el Nacho que hizo las predicciones.
Que se muera, que le peguen un tiro. No, por la calle no me pedís un tiro, pero que se muera.
Porque hoy os vamos a dar razones por las que esta gente se puede quedar en la Premier League.
Y la primera de todas las chozas es que los tres están practicando el fútbol de toda la vida de Dios.
Menos mal, por fin, gracias a Dios nos han hecho caso y se han dejado de chorradas.
Los tres están entre los cinco equipos con menos posesión de la Premier League.
¡Bravo! Enhorabuena, lo habéis entendido todo, tío.
Lo habéis entendido todo.
El Barley es el que menos con un 35,4%.
35% acosonante.
El Sunderland un 44,1% y el Leeds un 45,3%.
A ver, es verdad que hay diferencias.
El Barley es algo más tradicional y el Sunderland y el Leeds están tratando bastante mejor el balón que el Barley.
Y tienen altura, juego aéreo, son equipos bastante más físicos.
Hay diferencias entre ellos, pero oye, come back to the basics.
Fantástico, joven Macho. Qué inglés de Cambridge que tienes.
La madre que me parió.
Claro, es que volviendo a los básicos.
Estamos volviendo a los básicos y eso nos hace muy feliz.
Club por club, si hacemos el repaso vais a ver que al menos son equipos que, como recién ascendidos,
están cumpliendo lo primero que le pedimos a un club de estos.
Y empezamos por el que está volviendo a lo que queríamos ver, que es el Barley.
Nuestros amigos, los Clarets, ahí lo tenemos, por fin, ya era hora de volver a decir que con el Barley se acabó el Vogue Nonsense.
Ojo, que igual le volvemos a ver en Premier.
Este paso no queda mucho para ver a que es mi colega de Sondage.
Pero en Europa con el Forrest.
¿Te gustaría en el Forrest, Jesús?
Ni de coña.
Ni de coña, dice.
Amigos, en su última temporada en la Premier League el Barley tuvo un 46,9% de posesión media.
Se ha acabado ya el Barley modernito, ¿vale?
Ya se ha acabado esa other Vogue Nonsense.
Ahora defender y punto.
Y nos estamos acercando a ese fútbol Brexit.
Pero, chozas.
Quiero decirte que todavía no es momento de lanzar las campanas al vuelo.
Porque te quiero decir que aún no hemos llegado al esplendor del Barley.
Y tú dirás, hostia, el esplendor del Barley fue sin duda alguna con Sondage, aquel fútbol tan directo, inteligente.
Chris Wood, Ashley Barnes.
No, amigos, no.
Hay que irse a 2008.
Hostia.
Por alguna razón hubo la crisis que hubo en 2008.
Pero es que en 2008 es cuando el Barley era el equipo absolutamente reconocible como Club Brexit.
Y te voy a contar una historia.
En 2008 se enfrentaban al Ipswich Sound.
Y decidieron en el Barley hacer un espectáculo prepartido.
Un espectáculo prepartido que entre otras cosas implicaba la caída desde los cielos de un paracaidista.
El paracaidista, al aterrizar en Turf Moor, acabó esta guisa.
Efectivamente, amigos, este tipazo que agarró el paracaidas acabó atascado con el techo de una de las tribunas.
Y el partido sufrió una hora de retraso.
Están gallumbos, ¿no?
Una hora de retraso.
Bueno, es que el tío iba con la equipación del Barley.
Hostia.
¿Qué te parece?
La miradita hacia abajo de Macho Laqueliao.
Laqueliao.
No es la primera vez que veo esto.
Y si te cuento que una vez que se...
Bueno, no se ha ranudo el partido.
Empezó el partido, acabaron perdiendo 0-3 con un gol en propia.
El Ipswich se fue con los tres puntos, con tres goles.
Y el Barley, en una reunión dos días después, anuló, suspendió cualquier otra celebración prepartido
o espectáculo prepartido para evitar ridículos así.
Hombre, está bien, está bien pesado, ¿eh?
Está bien pesado.
¿Por qué os cuento esto?
Porque...
Qué superstición.
Ya es hora de volver al Barley de toda la vida.
Y no al Barley del Big Data y de Vincent Company.
No lo queremos más.
El equipo Brexit antes del Brexit, macho.
Vamos ahora con el Sunderland.
Los Black Cats que, bueno, vamos a ver el mejor ejemplo de que se está volviendo al fútbol como Dios manda.
Lo has denominado el fútbol como Dios manda.
Sí, sí, sí.
A ti el fútbol este del toquecito y tal, nada más.
Con los tres recién ascendidos no quiero tonterías.
Tonterías, tonterías.
Bueno, pues os vamos a hablar de un futbolista que nos gusta mucho.
Nordi Mukiyele, el central, con más ocasiones creadas en lo que va de Premier League, lleva ya cuatro ocasiones creadas.
Tiene narices.
¿Cómo lo ha conseguido?
Con auténticos melonazos como los que vais a ver.
¡Mira mi niño!
Increíble.
El lanzador de piedras Mukiyele.
Es que tiene huevos.
Mira la ocasión que generó contra el Palace y mira esta, me encantó esta imagen contra el Aston Villa, sacada la anterior de Premier League, esta de The Athletic.
Pero fijaos en la segunda cómo el Sunderland se coloca en el área como si fuera un córner.
¡Hombre, claro!
Y mira el Divu Martínez saliendo hasta casi, ya no es su primer palo, saliendo casi del área pequeña al área del portero para evitar que Nordi Mukiyele, Nordi el piedras Mukiyele, ponga el balón en el área.
El daño que están haciendo estos saques de banda.
Qué bonito macho, qué bonito.
Creo honestamente que ya este verano ha habido gente en los estádios de reclutamiento encargada de fichar un tío que me saque los saques de banda así.
Bueno, te voy a decir, Nordi además es un personaje simpático, un gran tío.
Me cae muy bien Nordi Mukiyele.
Un auténtico tipazo, la lió bien gorda en la eliminatoria de Champions del año pasado contra el Bayern de Munich.
Sí, él ya sabes que viene el Bayern Leverkusen y es nuestro nuevo, después de que se marchara Jordi, pues ahora nos quedamos con Nordi.
Nordi, es verdad.
Y con Nordi Mukiyele, pues quería también enseñaros la que lió en la expulsión que sufrió el Bayern Leverkusen, en una eliminatoria que le pasó por encima del Bayern Munich.
Y bueno, es una secuencia que me hace gracia, sobre todo por ver las caras.
Me vais a tener que disculpar porque no he podido pillarlo con la imagen en movimiento, entonces vais a ver todo el rato el botón de play.
Pero bueno, poligualmente Jesús, ahí tenéis el botón de play inconfumible.
Hombre, a ver Nordi, llevabas amarilla y le haces esa a nuestro amigo Coman.
Tiene pinta de que te vas a ir.
Te vas, te vas a ir.
Pero fíjate, es que me da hasta ternura ver las caras de Nordi Mukiyele cuando se da cuenta de que le van a echar justo después del pisoto.
Espera, espera, espera.
Dale a la siguiente, Jesús.
Dale a la siguiente.
¡Calla, calla, calla!
Coman, no digas nada.
Lo que he liado.
No te tires, cabrón.
Por favor, Coman, Coman, por supuesto.
Ya ha anotado los tacos del género.
No está fingiendo también, te digo, el pobre hombre.
¿Puedes poner la pantalla completa, Mukiyele, por favor, Jesús?
¡Hostia!
Y ahora, por favor, la última, que es cómo se dirige el árbitro.
Mira la última.
Mira el tío.
¡Árbitro!
Si tú no lo has visto, yo te afongo.
Bueno, Nordi Mukiyele, como os podéis imaginar, acabó no expulsado,
acabó completamente expulsado.
Me habría encantado ver la secuencia de imágenes al revés, tío.
Ir descubriendo qué coño ha pasado para que este pobre hombre acabara así.
Nordi, macho.
¡Véalo, véalo!
Bueno, Nordi Mukiyele, que como veis, pues acabó.
Acabo expulsado y ahora está mucho mejor en el Sunderland, donde es...
En el lobo.
...en Nordi el Piedras Mukiyele.
En fin, en el Lids también hemos querido destacar,
porque esto es un vídeo sobre los tres recién ascendidos,
algo que me hace muy feliz, o sea,
y es que Daniel Farkes se ha dejado de gilipolleces.
Hay que decirlo, además, así, con todas las palabras.
Se ha dejado de gilipolleces.
Daniel Farkes, me he ido para comparar a su Norwich de la temporada 19-20.
Un Norwich que odié con toda mi alma,
porque a un equipo, no, es que tenemos el balón, no,
es que queremos un juego propositivo, un juego asociativo.
Me da igual irme otra vez a segunda, me da igual hacer el ridículo.
Daniel, muy bien, los passes, pero nos han metido siete.
Bien.
Pero qué pases, niño.
El Norwich.
El Norwich de la temporada 19-20 tuvo un 49,1% de posesión.
Más que media liga.
Era el noveno con mayor posesión media.
Bien, acabó con unos espectaculares 21 puntos la liga
y se fue de cabeza a segunda división.
Viniendo de dónde venimos tampoco me parece.
C cuidado que se salva el Norwich.
Ahora me he ido al Lids United de la temporada 25-26 de Daniel Farkes.
Me he encontrado y pido, por favor, un aplauso también,
porque Pablo acaba de entrar a la reacción.
Amigos, el Lids de la 25-26 comparado con el Norwich de la 19-20
y por tanto el Daniel Farkes del presente tiene menos el balón,
hace más entradas y comete más faltas que aquel Norwich.
Mira qué foto.
Este es mi Lids, hombre.
Qué grande.
Este sí.
Este es mi Lids.
¿Por qué has escogido precisamente una foto de Son Lomstead?
Porque mete unas hostias, Son Lomstead.
Mete unas hostias.
No he visto nunca a una persona con la cara de buen tipo
y luego un fútbol de decir, hombre, macho, me estás metiendo unos viajes.
Vaya, Pablo, ¿te acuerdas cuando iba a fichar por el Lids
y no cambié el escudo y salía en el marco el Sandela ni tú?
No, no, por aquí no.
Por aquí no pasó.
¿Cómo que solo estaba el Sandela?
Bueno, amigos, el primer punto fundamental para creer
en la salvación de los tres es que el fútbol de toda la vida de Dios
ha regresado, pero hay más puntos
y es que el siguiente chozas tiene que ver con que,
aunque esto os sorprenda, hay gente que la mete, amigos.
Es oficial, hay gente que la mete.
¿Tú la metes?
Yo no la meto.
Bueno, pues hay gente que la mete.
En el Sandela hay alguno.
Hay alguno.
12 euros.
Se llama Wilson Isidor y lleva ya tres goles, tres golarros.
Cuidado, que está marcando buenos goles, además.
Y encima todos han sido en el Stadium of Light.
Ahí estáis viendo uno de ellos celebrando lo con Saka,
por supuesto, el gran capitán y la estrella del equipo
que también suma tres asistencias, tres goles de Isidor,
tres asistencias de Saka, todo fluye.
Bueno, pues Saka es el jugador, el tercer jugador
que más kilómetros ha hecho de toda la Premier League.
El tío, macho, pasan los años y...
No, no, una estrella.
No envejece, tío.
Mejor fichaje de esta primera.
No envejece.
Pues no va a estar lejos.
Mallenda, ojo, ha tocado ocho veces el balón en el área rival,
ha tirado dos veces a puerta y ha marcado un gol.
No está teniendo muchas el pobre hombre,
tampoco está teniendo muchos minutos, todo hay que decirlo.
Pero, eh.
Pero, oye, un goleto.
Dos tiros a puerta y un gol.
En conclusión, es raro en un recién extendido tener
a un delantero que ha marcado tres goles en tres partidos en casa,
a un tío que lleva tres asistencias
y a otro que en dos tiros a puerta ha marcado un gol.
Estos son buenas noticias, insisto,
viniendo de donde venimos.
Pero no es el único, porque si nos fijamos en el Burnley,
aquí es donde es la gran noticia de la temporada.
¿Quién se iba a esperar esto?
Jesús, ¿tú viste venir lo que vamos a contar a continuación?
Increíble.
Jadon Anthony, amigos, lleva cuatro goles y solo Erling Haaland
y Antoine Semenio llevan más goles que él en esta Premier League.
Mírales, si es que Milenkovich no se lo puede creer.
Pero, ¿quién es este?
Si no sé ni qué nombre pone en la espalda.
Si le sumas una asistencia son ya cinco goles generados
en siete jornadas de Jadon Anthony.
No lo vio él, no lo vimos nosotros, no lo vio nadie.
Pero es la realidad.
Por tanto, ser un recién ascendido y tener a un tío que está marcando tanto
me da también como para tener esperanzas de que se pueden salvar.
Su historial no nos daba pistas, que ya es su récord personal.
Récord personal en Premier.
Hostia, estaba el nivel bajo.
A ver, Choza, no te voy a engañar.
Como aquí es, hay que mencionar todo el rato a los tres equipos.
Aquí has tirado...
En el Leeds hay un problema.
Y es que en el Leeds todo el mundo es una escopeta de ferias.
Pero he conseguido sacar un dato positivo.
Y me gusta, me gusta que...
Ninguno de los tres equipos recién ascendeos
tiene tanta variedad de goleadores como el Leeds,
que tiene seis goleadores diferentes.
Su máximo goleador, Ocafor con dos goleadores.
Pero me da igual.
Oye, así no dependen tanto de otra gente.
Seis goleadores repartidos en...
Perdón, siete goles porque Ocafor lleva dos y el resto todos llevan uno.
Ahí está.
¿Puede ser el Stagg?
Hombre, es muy probable.
Luego hablaremos un poco de Antoine Stagg y de lo mucho que lo queremos.
No sé por qué.
Bueno, aparte de que la meten mucho,
ojo, cuidado porque hay otra cosa positiva que es que no se la meten tanto.
Cuidado que no se la están metiendo tanto.
Es importante meterla como que no te la metan.
Claro.
En los ámbitos que quieras decirme.
A mí no me la meten.
No te la meten mucho.
No, juego de defensa.
Y tampoco la meto mucho porque juego de defensa.
Pero bueno, no le mantiene ahí en ese equilibrio.
Bien, buen rendimiento defensivo.
Por lo general, ninguno de los tres ha sufrido grandes humillaciones,
que a esto nos acostumbraron mucho la temporada pasada.
O incluso malas rachas.
Y en varias ocasiones se han quedado incluso cerca de sacar algún punto
más de los que tienen.
Por ejemplo, el Barley ha caído por un solo gol contra el Manchester United.
¿Y qué gol?
Si alabábamos antes a Gido Nanzoni,
también hay que darle aquí un...
¿Fue Gido Nanzoni, no?
¿El de este penalti?
Sí, el que agarra con la camiseta por detrás.
Sí, en mayoría es contra el Liverpool.
Y contra el Liverpool.
Y el Aston Villa también han perdido solo por un gol.
Ahí está el gol de Salah, el que estamos diciendo,
del penalti de Aníbal Medri.
Oye, haber perdido solo por un gol contra el Manchester United,
Liverpool y Villa, no está mal.
Está muy bien.
Solo, entre comillas, el solo ha recibido goleadas
contra el Tottenham y contra el Manchester City.
Bueno, cosas que pueden pasar.
Insisto, en este vídeo hemos venido a ser optimistas.
Cosas que pueden pasar.
Resimistas, puertas.
Pero ojo, que además de eso, ya han ganado a un rival directo como el Sunderland.
Le sacaron un 2-0 y han batado contra el Forrest.
Que bueno, que a día de hoy el Forrest es un poco una feria, pero oye, ahí está.
Conclusión, no solo ha peleado el Barley,
sino que ya se ha quitado a cuatro del Big Six,
a dos clubes de competición europea como el Forrest y el Aston Villa,
y a la revelación de esta temporada como es su rival directo,
el Sunderland y su calendario, pues ha sido bastante duro y ahora va a mejorar mucho.
Es que cuidado con eso, que llevan cuatro puntos,
pero el calendario ha sido muy puñetero para el Barley.
Y de hecho, el partido que digamos que tenías que ganar,
ha sido siquiera el del Sunderland, lo ha ganado.
Ahora le vino un calendario en el que va a poder puntuar mejor,
si se normaliza ese nivel de...
Cuatro Big Six en siete jornadas.
Hombre, no es un calendario mal.
Y Scott Parker sigue con trabajo.
Las cosas están yendo de una manera bastante sorprendente.
Ni el segundo entrenador en ese match.
¿Y qué hay de los otros dos?
Bueno, en el caso del Leeds United...
A ver, hay que descartar un resultado, que fue 5-0 contra el Arsenal.
No pasa nada.
Pero a partir de ahí,
la verdad es que sus partidos han sido realmente ajustados
y las otras dos derrotas han sido por la mínima contra Fulham y Tottenham.
Y además contra Tottenham...
Cuidado.
Por lo general no he visto un Leeds que se haya desconectado de los partidos
y acordaros que otros años, desde el principio,
la que le está cayendo a los tres recién ascendidos.
Cuando han perdido lo han peleado, menos el partido del Arsenal,
y cuando no, han puntuado.
Y además tengo que deciros que el Leeds este año,
incluso en las malas, perdiendo contra el Tottenham,
ha demostrado que tiene una afición que es señora.
Afición señora, afición solidaria.
Una afición que incluso en el vicio,
no en el fornicio, pero sí en el vicio,
comparte con los jugadores.
No es el mejor de los vicios, se lo podían quitar,
pero aún así dice, ¿quieres una caladita?
Yo te la doy, Pedro Porro.
No había otro jugador al que darle precisamente un vapeador.
Pues ahí lo tenéis, amigos.
¡Ay, es verdad esto!
Efectivamente.
Increíble.
La afición del Leeds compartiendo el vicio,
lanzándole un vapeador rosa al bueno de Pedro Porro,
que dice, primero, efectivamente es de fresa,
buen sabor, me gusta.
Un segundo, árbitro, ¿dónde me meto en esto?
No sé, no me lo ves, árbitro.
Me han tirado.
Luego el porredes dijo, a ver, no me apetecía vapear en ese momento,
prefiero los tres puntos.
Y me los ha llevado, cracks.
Pedro…
Creo que no lo llega a…
O sea, creo que hace solo como el gesto,
no se lo llega a meter en la boca.
No vaya a ser que le haya enviado el vapeador.
Claro, eso es.
No puede esperar cualquier cosa.
Inteligente, Pedro.
Porro vapeando, ¿eh?
Claro, vapeando porro.
Bueno, bueno, bueno.
Vapeando porro.
Porro vapeador.
Luego nos estamos dejando uno que es el Sunderland.
Por supuesto que hay poco que decir sobre los partidos
en los que se cayeron por un poco,
porque solo han perdido dos partidos,
que esto también es muy noticiable.
Es que claro.
Solo tienen dos derrotas.
De ellos no se puede decir,
no, bueno, han estado siempre en los partidos,
si es que apenas han perdido.
Claro.
Que están muy bien.
La única pena, entre comillas,
para el Sunderland es que perdieron contra un rival directo
como el Barley, pero a partir de ahí han seguido en buena línea.
Y sí se puede decir de ellos que están especializándose
en victorias tardías.
Contra el West Ham, por ejemplo,
el primer gol llega en el minuto 61,
al Brenford le remontan con uno en el 82 y otro en el 96,
y al Villa le arrancan un punto con uno menos,
o sea, con un gol en el 75.
Y bueno, en una de sus derrotas,
en la de Old Trafford contra el Manchester United,
pues sus aficionados dieron ejemplo
al limpiar el estadio de...
Ahí está.
Muy bien.
Hombre.
Muy bien también por parte de la afición del Sunderland,
Chozas, si me preguntas por qué acudes a Old Trafford,
hombre.
Te llevas una derrota y bueno, esto ya depende de...
Y te llevas una mascota.
O te llevas una mascota o directamente has ido a la limpieza de Old Trafford,
que como veis, pues sigue teniendo un problema de ratas y ratones.
¡Ojé, macho!
¿Cómo lo ves?
Eh...
¡Pobre animal, eh!
Pobre animal lo que ha tenido que pasar.
Espero que no se haya bebido lo que hubiera dentro.
Hay que tener puntería también, te digo,
para meterlo en un vaso de plástico, eh.
Hombre, entiendo cómo ha sido, que ha sido haciéndolo...
Sí, sí, pero un ratón es rápido, eh.
Un ratón, macho.
Sí, hombre, claro, pero entre 300 piernas por ahí,
el pobre animal estaría ahí.
Pues ahí lo tienes, la afición del Sunderland
también ha ido andando a limpiar un poco Old Trafford, ¿no?
¿Se lo habrá llevado a casa?
¿Qué decir? ¿Se ha ido en Ratcliffe?
Sí, bueno, sí.
Así que el nuevo estadio va a estar guapo,
pero a ver si primero vaciamos el piso de roedores.
Si no es mucho pedir.
¿Qué harías vosotros con este ratón?
Yo me lo quedo de más cosa, eh.
Hombre, por favor.
Hombre, tú solo has alguno de tus hijos machos...
¡No, no, no!
...y hacen maravillas con ellos, Jesús.
Joder, sí, pobrecito.
Son todos maravillas, lo cocinan.
¡Madre mía!
¡Mamá!
Eso sería lo mejor que le pudiese pasar al pobre animal,
sería que lo cocinaran.
Eso sería lo mejor.
Madre mía.
Bueno, amigos, ejemplares.
Ejemplares como ya habéis las aficiones de Lich y Sunderland
entre el vapeador y limpiar Old Trafford de ratas.
Otra de las razones por las que somos muy optimistas
con estos tres recién ascendidos en este inicio de temporada
es que efectivamente hay carisma.
Me alegra mucho deciros que hay carisma.
Ese es intangible, fundamental para mantenerte en la Premier League.
Necesitas, futbolistas, que tengan ese algo que va más allá del fútbol.
Aura, macho.
Hay uno en cada equipo.
He querido elegir a uno en cada equipo.
Y ahora volvemos a uno que habíamos mencionado antes
y que ya os hemos hablado de él en algún directo.
Pero en el Lich United está mi hombre, Anton Stagg,
el auténtico Instagramer, el segundo tío que más kilómetros ha hecho
en esta Premier League, autor de un espectacular gol de falta
contra los Wolverhampton Wanderers.
Pero no es eso lo importante.
Lo importante es su Instagram.
Míralo al muchacho cómo en Instagram se divierte
desde Criaturas de Madagascar después de debutar en la Premier League,
que tú irás, normalmente la gente debuta en Premier League
y se hace un vídeo, su equipo de redes de la hostia y súper épico tal.
No, este se pone con el León de Madagascar y con lo otro que no sé muy bien ni qué es.
Al lado...
Un cacho de carne con la forma de una cebra, ¿no?
Sí, exacto.
Como si estuviera cortado en un cacho de carne.
Parteando, que no acabo de entender muy bien
en qué película de Madagascar sale eso.
Vamos a ver otro ejemplo de nuestro amigo Anton Stagg.
También es un beatle, como podéis ver.
Diciendo que acaban de cruzar el paso de la pre-temporada
por hacer alguna traducción mínimamente fiable.
Y la siguiente parada es la Premier League.
Y por último, y lo vemos también en uno de esos primeros entrenamientos
con el Leeds United fregando el suelo.
Es un tipo de que genuinamente se lo pasa bien usando canva.
Porque sabe Dios que esto lo ha hecho canva.
Y lo ha hecho él.
Bueno, a ver, te digo, cuidado, yo en canva ese charco no lo sé hacer.
Bueno, esto es verdad.
Ahora hay que darle una vuelta a dos.
Y la fregona queda muy bien cogida, ¿eh?
Sí, sí, sí.
Queda muy bien cogida.
El cartel no está conseguido.
Está flotando.
La fregona queda muy bien cogida.
Que será una frase que tendrá buena llegada a Argentina.
Sí.
Hablando de Argentina, Tiago, nuestro miniaturista del canal.
Mucho Photoshop, mucho tal.
Pero lo de la fregona te lo hago yo mejor con canva que lo con Photoshop.
Hombre, pero mil veces.
Tú te tienes ese punto cutre.
Ese punto cutre que no acaba de pillar, Tiago.
Esto, el punto cutre se está hablando mucho, ¿eh?
Esto es el punto cutre.
Sí, el punto cutre.
Es algo muy mencionado últimamente.
Chozas, tengo ahora que hablarte de otro nivel.
¿Qué nivel?
Porque ahora te voy a hablar del Burnley.
Y en el Burnley, amigos, lo que viene a continuación va a poner en duda
todos los estándares de belleza que hasta ahora considerabais
válidos y establecidos.
Porque, qué demonios, ya esto no es ni siquiera en el fútbol.
Os tengo que dar una noticia.
Miradme muy fijamente.
No el futbolista.
El hombre más guapo del mundo es peruano.
Por la foto, Jesús, por la foto.
Tío, es una cosa.
Es Big Four en guapo.
Es todo el mundo en guapo, Chozas.
Es tú en guapo, es yo en guapo.
Os presento.
Pero me compras que se parece a Big Four.
A cualquier persona guapa.
Entonces, le está llamando en NPC.
Os presento a Oliver Soene, nacido en Dinamarca.
Pero, un momento, has dicho peruano.
Lo has dicho como Gaspi, macho.
No.
Nacido en Dinamarca.
No, coño.
¿Qué? ¿No me dejas hablar?
Nacido en Dinamarca, pero su abuela materna nació en Perú.
Y, por tanto, Oliver es peruano.
Es peruano con todas las letras y ha jugado ya con la selección peruana.
¿Cómo te quedas?
Increíble.
Y si te digo además que de joven fue modelo.
De joven más joven aún.
Hombre, esto me lo creo más.
Vale.
Y si te digo además que es el sobrino de Elena Christensen,
que es una modelo de fama internacional.
Bueno, no la conozco.
Pero me crees.
No la conozco, pero te tengo que creer.
Pero que Oliver ha llegado a salir en revistas de moda y de todo por razones evidentes.
Por lo guapo que es.
Es una familia de gente exageradamente guapa.
Y, insisto, es peruano.
No, nació en Dinamarca.
Shh, peruano.
Peruano.
Pero peruanísimo.
Es muy peruano.
O sea, como podéis ver.
Más peruano que Lima.
No, no.
¿Esa chaqueta qué es?
De Dinamarca.
No, claro.
Esa chaqueta es muy peruana.
Por tanto, ¿eh?
¿Leís Dinamarca por algún lado?
No.
Oliver ha decidido jugar para Perú y, por tanto, es completamente peruano.
Pero, una cosa, ¿Perú se ha metido en el mundial?
No lo sé.
Pero tengo una cosa que contarte, Chozas.
Cuéntame.
Que esto es por lo que ha habido un momento, ¿vale?
Preparando este guión que la gente me ha visto llorar de risa.
Pues, tomando informaciones y demás.
Y esta era la razón.
Porque mi hermano Oliver, como nació en Dinamarca, es muy...
No se han metido, ¿eh?
Es muy peruano.
Pero el español, el castellano, no lo maneja muy bien todavía, ¿vale?
Y en una entrevista con un medio, supongo que peruano,
pues le quisieron animar un poco a...
Oye, algunas palabritas en español y tal.
Y él dijo, bueno, venga.
Y le preguntaron qué cosas le gusta hacer el día a día.
¡Hastía!
Y el pobre se lanza a la respuesta.
No os puedo poner el vídeo, por si nos lo bloquean por derechos.
Pero el vídeo iba acompañado de subtítulos.
Y entonces los subtítulos dicen exactamente, o más o menos, lo que él dice.
Entonces vamos a verlo.
Que el pobre al principio dice, bueno, me gusta beber café con mi novia.
Con mi novia.
Con leche, no, con mi novia.
El problema es lo que viene después.
Porque el pobre Oliver dice, hombre, no voy a decir solo beber café con mi novia.
Y aquí Oliver...
Se suelta, ¿no?
No, no, no es que se suelta.
A ver si lo entiendes tú, porque a mí me ha costado mucho.
Dale, el siguiente, Jesús.
Y me gustaría caminar con mi pierna en orden.
Eh...
Que alguien me explique que quería...
He querido dejar además...
He querido dejar además la imagen de la entrevista ahora a la derecha.
Diciendo, bueno, Oliver, a mí también me gustaría caminar con mi pierna.
Sobre todo que pusieras las palabras en orden.
El pobre, yo deduzco, yo deduzco, qué quería decir.
A ver, para empezar, no conjuga bien el verbo y en vez de me gusta dice me gustaría.
Todo el rato.
Me gustaría caminar.
Y entonces él tú dices, creo que en vez de perro dice pierna.
Y esto lo dice claramente.
Claramente.
Y entonces dice, me gustaría caminar con mi pierna.
Y entonces es a la entrevista, mirándole con esta cara y diciendo, creo que no ha sido buena idea.
Decirle a Oliver que me hable en español.
Pero y lo de en orden?
Y en orden yo creo que es porque él suelta como una palabra en danés que debe ser como diciendo perro.
Porque en ese momento tiene un cruceo de cables.
Y entonces dice como...
Y entonces el de los subtítulos ha puesto en orden.
Y pone una manita y unos besos.
Los emoticones son los mejores.
El conmilla con una sonrisa de se viene.
Se viene lo que va a decir el salvaje.
Madre de Dios.
Me gustaría caminar con mi pierna.
Bueno, a cabo no tiene sus gustos.
Tengo como gusto caminar con la pierna en orden.
Y ahí tenéis al entrevistador.
El entrevistador que no sabía muy bien dónde meterse.
Pues con esta son normalidad me he tirado llorando de risa.
Pero te has tirado un buen rato.
Qué risa lo de caminar con mi pierna en orden.
Qué guapo es Oliver Sonny.
Es muy guapo.
Que tío es muy guapo y muy peruano.
Qué guapo es.
Muy guapo y muy peruano.
Pero no hemos terminado de hablar de Carisma porque todavía queda el Sunderland.
No voy a decir que no es tan guapo.
Bueno, es un tío de vuelta.
No sé si es tan gracioso.
Pero es un personaje de cuidado.
Estamos hablando de Luke O'Nagin.
O'Nagin, jugador del Sunderland.
El equipo que nos faltaba en esta categoría.
Pero queremos que estéis atentos a cuando le toque jugar contra el Bournemouth.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque se va a reencontrar con Alex Scott.
El hombre al que decidió...
La palabra es literal.
Montar.
Al que decidió montar.
No se te ha ocurrido otra manera de definirlo para evitar un ataque.
Vais a verlo.
¿Cómo lo definirías tú, Chozas?
Ahí está.
No.
Esto es montar a alguien.
Le ha pedido que le lleve a Titi.
No.
Esto es montar a alguien.
Alex Scott, que como ya sabéis, tiene muy buena conducción de balón.
Rompete líneas.
De todo esto.
Estaba avisado Luke O'Nagin que dijo, espérame.
Me va a conducir a mí.
Ahora también lo voy a convertir en potro.
Efectivamente, no solo se le subió a la espalda, sino que además no encontró una imagen frontal perfecta.
Pero le dio un beso en la mejilla ante la estupefacción de Alex Scott.
Alex Scott, que va a pedir a Andoni Rahola que tanto en la primera vuelta como en la segunda
contra el Sunderland, sí puede ser que no esté convocado.
Le van a saltar.
Un segundo.
¿El besito se lo da con el balón en juego todavía?
No, no.
Ahí el árbitro ya había pitado.
Ya llevaba unos cuantos metros con Luke O'Nagin montando a Alex Scott como si se tratara de un potro.
El árbitro tuvo que parar lo que era, a todas las luces, una...
¿Un atropello?
No, no.
Un acto sexual.
Tenía que pararlo como fuera.
Por un tema de coro.
Le da un besito.
Sí, sí, sí.
Entonces, cardio.
Beso cariñoso de decirle...
Sobre todo, imagínate que ese día Luke O'Nagin es titular y Alex Scott también.
En el pasamanos este, ¿qué hace Luke O'Nagin?
Darle un beso otra vez.
Se saca la chorra y dice, choqui, choqui.
Ya confianzas.
La frontera del beso ya la hemos pasado.
¿Qué es lo siguiente?
Hombre, es verdad que una vez que hay beso, pues ya lo siguiente.
Es verdad que ya lo siguiente.
O nada.
Bueno, ya es como romper una presa.
A partir de ahí, pues el agua fluye.
Bueno, amigos, y para terminar, porque sé que ya tenéis razones de sobra para pensar
que los T recién extendidos se van a mantener en la Premier League, pero queda una razón más.
Vuelvo a excluir al League United aquí, ¿vale?
Vaya.
Sí, porque quiero hablaros de los porteros.
Están siendo una de las grandes razones por las que los equipos en los que juegan en la
la
zona prudente.
Es verdad que en el caso del League United a Perry no lo hemos visto demasiado.
Solo tres partidos, pero ojo cuidado.
Dos porterías a cero en tres partidos y hombre, Cal Darlow, pues ya ha tenido alguna.
No, sí, aquel paradón que le hizo a Kevin, lo que tú quieras.
Darlow necesita que vuelva a Perry cuanto antes.
Que vuelva a Perry en el ornitorrinco.
En el ornitorrinco.
Y porque no te está gustando Meslier.
Ya.
Pregúntale a Andrés Weiss por la Meslier.
Pero sí hay que mencionar lo que están haciendo tanto Robin Roeffs como Martin Dubravka.
En el caso de Martin Dubravka, el antiguo Jesucristo del Newcastle ha sido ya nominado
a la parada del MES por esta parada que hizo en uno de los partidos del Burnley.
Si no me equivoco, es contra el Forrest, efectivamente.
Ahí lo tenéis con esa estirada que vais a verlo a continuación.
Como no tenemos los derechos, pues os lo ponemos en fotos porque es lo que hay.
Si no, nos banean el canal.
Y está además en positivo la diferencia entre goles encajados y goles esperados.
Se está parando mucho y bien.
Me gusta cuando esta estadística se corresponde con lo que ves en los partidos.
Y dices, hombre, mis sensaciones que Martin Dubravka está dándole mucho más de lo que le está quitando al Burnley.
Y así está sucediendo.
Pero ahora vamos con el bicho.
Es el Mad Shells de este año.
La sorpresa.
Y en siete jornadas te diría que hasta más bestia.
Porque...
Bueno, es que...
A ver, lo de Refs va mucho más allá.
El portero de Sunderland...
¿Te acuerdas cuando lo ficharon que nos reíamos de...
Pero dónde va esta gente fichando al portero del...
Venía del Negni Mega, ¿no?
Yo creo que era el portero...
Sí, creo que es el portero del...
No veo los partidos del Negni Mega.
No, pero cuando vino...
Decían, joe, el portero del Negni Mega, ¿dónde vas fichando para mantenerte?
A ver, si sacaba ahora mismo la Premier, es el mejor punto de la Premier.
Sin ninguna duda.
Casi un 80% de paradas sobre el total de disparos.
Ha evitado casi tres goles según la estadística avanzada.
Pero no solo te lo digo con los datos, también vamos a verlo.
Son tantas paradas que me ha dado para hacer un carrusel,
una recopilación de un montón de acciones heroicas de Refs.
Otra vez con capturas para que veáis la dificultad de muchas de esas intervenciones.
Esta, para mí incluso, pasa un poco por debajo del radar.
Es un paradón que hace en la victoria contra el Forest.
Fijaos el disparo limpísimo de Omar y Hutchinson.
Y aunque no he conseguido la mejor de las capturas,
mira en la siguiente foto cómo la para con esa reacción abajo.
Una parada dificilísima con el pie, donde muchos intentarían ir abajo con la mano
y repele un balón que, de verdad, a esa distancia es muy difícil reaccionar.
Puede parecer fácil, pero la distancia tan corta a la que está, el tiro no era flojo.
Y luego, sobre todo, que también tiene defensas por delante
que no le permiten ver tan claro el balón, me parece.
Ese es un paradón, pero no es el último.
Vamos a ver más, porque hay muchos.
Aquí lo que he querido destacar es que es una parada que también está bien.
Del mismo partido en tal no tengan Forest.
Pero, como puedes ver, hay infiltrados en el Sunderland.
En este caso es Arthur Masuaku, que me tendrás que explicar
qué estaba celebrando en esa jugada.
Porque es de todos ellos, de todos los futbolistas,
el único que tiene los brazos en alto y tú irás.
Está diciendo que nadie la ha tocado.
Yo aquí lo que veo es un Arthur Masuaku a punto de celebrar el gol del Nottingham Forest.
Estaría bueno.
Que alguien me explique qué está haciendo Arthur Masuaku con los brazos en alto.
Yo creo que le está diciendo, tranquilo, no tiene nadie detrás.
Puedes escogerla tranquilamente.
¿Es un infiltrado, Arthur Masuaku?
¿Está buscando un contrato con el Nottingham Forest ahora que no tiene laterales?
Hostia, no está dando mucho de razón.
Solo celebrar un gol no creo que sea demasiada razón.
Me alegra constatar que la vista de Chozas no es muy buena de lejos,
pero la gente en casa sí estará viendo lo que ha revelado la fotografía
encima de Arthur Masuaku.
Tú sé que no lo estás viendo.
Pásalo, Jesús.
Quien no tiene la vista fina se pierde los detalles del vídeo.
Vamos con la siguiente parada.
Lo ves en casa.
La parada quizá, quizá candidata ya no a parada del mes,
sino parada de la temporada.
La que le hace a Bruno Fernández, que como veis desde la frontal del área
dispara un disparo que prima más la colocación que la potencia.
Pero vamos a ver la siguiente imagen que se aprecia mejor.
La estirada increíble para con la punta de los dedos
y después de corregir con varios pasos laterales llevar el balón al larguero.
Si vemos a la izquierda, Brian Embuomo ya estaba celebrando el gol.
Esta es de las mejores de la temporada.
Si vemos a la jornada 7, así se va a mantener seguro.
Otro infiltrado.
En este caso era su equipo.
Si tienes algo con lo que excusar a Masuaku,
en este caso tiene sentido.
Masuaku, en cambio, no tiene explicación.
Si la tiene, como habéis visto en la imagen, menos chozas.
Vamos a la siguiente.
Esta también es una salvajada parada.
Fijaos lo limpio que es el disparo de Matetá
y la distancia a la que está el portero.
Vamos a la siguiente.
El hombro de Robin Roeps también se vuelve a interponer
para otra de las grandes paradas de esta temporada.
Entre esta y la anterior podemos estar hablando de dos de las más increíbles.
Vale que en esta se la encuentro un poco más, pero hay que estar.
Llevamos parada con el pie, parada con la mano, parada con el hombro.
Este dio parada como paranda.
Mas fotos.
En siete jornadas da para tanto.
También he detectado cierto anti-japonesismo de mi amigo Robin Roeps.
No le gustan los japoneses y en concreto Kamada.
Le arruinó la tarde a Kamada.
Le hizo primero este paradón y luego vamos a ver otra parada más
que le hizo al bueno de Kamada.
En este caso Kamada ya estaba casi dado la vuelta para celebrar el gol.
Toma paradón que le hizo a la escuadra la afición del palas.
Lo que me da la idea de que se haya parado Roeps en el mismo partido.
Esto fue una exhibición individual impresionante.
No veo, pero a la derecha, no sé si es Ismail Hazard, no lo sé,
pero no está haciendo como, oye, ¿qué pasa, tío?
Es Gegi, ¿no?
Vas a parar de parar en algún momento.
Está con los brazos así este, tío.
Vas a parar de parar, yeah.
Vamos con la siguiente imagen.
Aquí tenemos otra también muy meritoria contra el West Ham United.
Lleva varias de estas, eh.
Todas además de unos reflejos, una elasticidad,
un balón arriba en un cabezazo de Callum Wilson,
también fundamental en el primer partido del Sunderland en esta Premier League.
Pues aquí también se estapó como el gran portero que es.
Seguimos avanzando en este carrusel.
Aquí os doy otra imagen más de lo meritoria que es esta parada,
que insisto, este balón iba dentro.
Aquí cuando lo veis volando ya ha tocado Robin Roeps el balón.
Y vamos con alguna más.
Creo que es la última, pero es que claro,
con lo que te he enseñado, digo, joder, qué mérito Roeps,
es que también ha parado un penalti.
Es increíble.
Por si no avalía solo con eso, le ha parado un penalti al Brent Fork,
a Kevin Schade.
De verdad que es rozar la perfección en cuanto a la cantidad de paradas
y salvadas que le ha hecho al Sunderland en esta temporada.
Hombre, si tienes un portero así inspirado, te vas a quedar en la Premier League.
Seguro.
Esto ya no es fe, esto es certeza.
¿Te he convencido?
Me has convencido mucho.
Este último apartado me ha dejado ya satisfecho.
Finalmente satisfecho.
En el list tengo dudas.
Amigos, os esperamos en comentarios para que nos digáis.
¿Vosotros creéis en la salvación de los 3 recién ascendidos?
Por fin tendremos una pelea por la salvación digna
de lo que debería ser una liga como la Premier League.
Se van a salvar los 3 recién llegados,
se van a ir 3 dinosaurios que ya huele el hueco que están ocupando en la Premier League.
Demasiado.
Contándonoslo en comentarios.
Y si sois pesimistas, no nos dejéis ningún comentario.
Este vídeo es solo para optimistas, solo para los que creen.
Y te lo estoy diciendo yo que soy el Newcastle.
Desciende el Manchester City.
Son palabras de Pablo Espinoza.
Y el Liverpool.
El Liverpool además con jornadas por disputar.
Sí, sí.
Bien.
Y sanción de 20 puntos para el Everton.
Claro.
Y Arnest Lodz confirma que es un Harkonnen.
Y que todo es lo que va a tocar.
Bueno, tampoco veo tan loca la predicción.
Oh Pablo, qué valiente.
Nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.
Perdón por todo.